here with Chairman Tom Wheeler Tom last
week you approved some new net
neutrality regulations now here you are
in the belly of the beast Mobile World
Congress how has the reception been
among your former friends here in the
wireless industry I think they're my
former friends bred though I think that
the most interesting thing is how
anxious everybody is to learn exactly
what the rules are about and how we
structured them in such a way that
they're built on the mobile model we've
built them around what has worked for
the last 22 years in terms of regulating
the wireless industry in the United
States so that we could make sure that
there was adequate investment that would
continue to come as a result of the fact
that there is no rate regulation no tera
f---ing and those traditional kinds of
monopolies regulation that you heard so
much about during the debate and so what
the feeling that I'm getting here and
talking to people is they're saying well
as I understand it better you know and
it's significant I mean you sprint has
come out and said they support it
t-mobile has said that they'll continue
investing under this Google Fiber has
said even though we are now a title to
common carrier we will continue to
investigate the small wireless carriers
have said hey I think this is something
we can live with you know on and on and
on there has been a list of people who
have said well the more we get past the
rhetoric and the more we get to what
really what's going on here then perhaps
this is something we could the road
ahead be that easy - should we expect
some litigation similar to all we saw at
the 2010 proposal the big dogs have
promised that they're going to litigate
you know and one of the funny things
Brad about it is that is that everybody
talks about oh this 317 page border the
rules actually take up eight pages
and the other 309 pages are the
explanation which in many cases is
talking to the court because we know
that the big dogs are going to take us
to court I'm your personal journey to
net neutrality I mean you you were a
lobbyist for the cable and telecom
industry right you headed the CTIA for
many years what was the Epiphany for you
at the FCC you know that brought about
last week for Olli it's interesting
Craig who's actually long before that
I've been a proponent of open networks
before the word the terms net neutrality
were ever invented because everybody
talks to me all wheeler former lobbyist
what they also leave out is former
entrepreneur who's started half a dozen
companies former venture capitalists who
understood the importance of open
internets and access to networks and and
so I walked into this job being a strong
proponent of open networks did the very
public statement by the Obama
administration last November play a role
in the new rules so we had been going
through a whole process I had proposed
in February a set of rules that took a
slightly different approach using what's
called section 706 but also asked the
question about should we use title 2 and
between that period in February and are
made to the middle of summer I met with
a whole bunch of consumers and
innovators and investors who all said
there's a real problem in the approach
you were looking at because the test
there was the term commercial
reasonableness what's a Murshid
reasonable and they said if this is
determined subsequently to mean what is
reasonable for the ISPs for the network
operators that will be a mistake
and I said okay I get it I understand
that let's start going back to the old
test of what's just and reasonable and
the way you get to that is you use title
to the Communications Act so then when
you use type
to the communications I could say okay
how do I not bring along all of the
excess baggage of this traditional
monopoly style regulation and we pattern
that on what worked for the wireless
industry because for 22 years the
wireless industry has been regulated as
a common carrier under title ii with a
list of things that were left out of the
old-style regulation invest in new
technology they've invested 300 billion
dollars in related questions
you recently had a spectrum auction dish
is one of the big winners everybody is
screaming about how dish won in that
auction do they have a valid point
so we did it under the rules that were
established back in toward 2006
interestingly enough for the upcoming
auction that we have for spectrum that
will take place next year or the
broadcast spectrum we opened a
rulemaking long before this current
contra Tom to ask the question what
should be the new rules for these kinds
of designated entities and that's a
proceeding that's underway right now and
will be concluded and will guide what we
do in the rule and the option that takes
place next year chairman wheeler thank
you very much for joining us thank you